so Maxwell so um out of your many years
on Dancing With the Stars who were your
most memorable Partners who do you think
not to just the others just who's
somebody that stood out my wife oh well
good answer yeah my wife why you're
still married
it's a pleasure one of the biggest
Pleasures is the dynamic personalities
and people that you go through this
process with and and it's I don't want
to say a gauntlet but it is something
that really brings people together uh
and one of the partners that I had a
privilege to be a pro partner with on
dancing with the star of Zendaya oh yeah
yeah
yeah I forgot
and Dad she was young right she was 16
and she was just kind of trying to
transition out of the Disney yeah uh
star and yeah the rest is history that
and yeah that's great that's a crazy
career that one she's so talented so
talented so max does it ever bother you
that um Val won twice and and you know
you won once I'm disappointed I mean it
doesn't bother me because rub it in
because he won twice my wife won twice
okay his wife won twice oh my gosh I'm
holding it down not yourself my
six-year-old was in my wife's belly I
guess when they weren't together so he
has a half a trophy I only have one in
17 Seasons but you know I gotta say that
my best partner was probably the show
itself oh you know 17 seasons of
incredible opportunities uh look at us
now yeah so we're grateful that's a
great answer yeah because people don't
like that's so I don't know that's one
of the reasons why I love being part of
the voice too it's like it it does that
for other artists like not all the
artists you're working with but also the
coaches it like kind of lets you kind of
reinvent yourself too in a way and
that's really cool how shows allow
people to really stretch their creative
muscles
well we kind of like take for granted
sometimes is the people that we gathered
in those shows are your core fans your
core audience it's the support system
that you have nowadays social media
craziness we can rely on people we've
never met I don't even know where they
live but I can always get this nice
message that makes me feel like you know
what I'm gonna go out I'm gonna do it
again no matter what the critics say
because there's people that really
that's why you're really here that's
I like to support you I'm gonna buy it
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]